keinen waffenstillstand keine
friedensverhandlungen der krieg in der
ukraine geht weiter aber die europäische
welt die ordnet sich schon jetzt neu der
ukrainische aussenminister kollegah ist
heute zu gast bei seinen kollegen der
g7-staaten beim außenministertreffen in
deutschland in der eu da möchte er gerne
schon einmal einen platz für sein land
reservieren und auch die nato erhält
zuwachs finnland hat heute entschieden
teil des verteidigungsbündnisses werden
zu wollen und schweden will folgen wie
wird putin darauf reagieren wird es den
verlauf des krieges beeinflussen
bündnisse gegen putin wie die verändert
der krieg nato und eu unser thema heute
in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend herzlich willkommen
hier aus berlin ich darf meine gäste
vorstellen ich begrüße ganz herzlich ihr
lehmkuhl die französische journalistin
in deutschland unter anderem für journal
du dimanche und dem belgischen rundfunk
und sie hat auch einen podcast über
deutsch-französische beziehungen und
herzlich willkommen rolf-dieter krause
ehemaliger leiter des europa studios der
ard in brüssel zugeschaltet ist uns dr
veronika priesmeier coach die
stellvertretende direktorin der
europäischen akademie berlin und mit
dieser bildungseinrichtung hat sie den
gesamten prozess der eu-osterweiterung
intensiv begleitet und sie stammt aus
polen und in stockholm ist uns carl erik
normann zugeschaltet er ist ehemaliger
botschafter schwebens er war als
diplomat in moskau genf rom und peking
tätig hermann an sie auch direkt erstmal
die erste frage heute die entscheidungen
in finnland dass man vorschlagen will
eben der nato beizutreten
präsident und parlament haben der
präsident hatte und die
ministerpräsidentin haben sich dazu
ausgesprochen und die schweden wollen
folgen wie kommt das so schnell die zwei
länder die so lange neutral waren die
jetzt so schnell sagen wir wollen doch
teil der nato werden
ja alles ist wo leute sie viel schneller
laufen
als man sich vorstellen konnte
aber wir konnten uns auch nicht diese
invasion in ukraine vorstellen und die
eu hat schnell reagiert die ganze welt
hat reagiert und
zwei länder die lange neutral waren
finnland schweden haben auch reagiert
die ihre
meinungsbildung sowohl in finnland
schweden hat sich radikal geändert
vor
vor dem 24
februar war
in den beiden ländern für nato
mitgliedschaft
gibt es eine klare mehrheit in finnland
sogar drei viertel der bevölkerung drei
viertel der des parlaments und den
schweden würde ich wohl sagen mindesten
zweiten drittel und mehr
schnell schneller als man sich hätte
vorstellen können und wird schweden
dabei von finnland getrieben oder ist es
unabhängig voneinander zu sehen
es ist so dass
sicherheitspolitik sind schweden und
finnland immer sehr nah aneinander man
hat einander
unterstützt und
versucht also dieselbe position zu
nehmen man darf nicht vergessen dass
finnland 600 jahre
eine union mit schweden hatten anteil
von schweden war wie man es ausdrücken
will ja man soll auch sicher wenn das in
der kritische periode nach finnlands 100
jahre nach teil von russland und dann 20
jahre zwischen den ersten und zweiten
weltkrieg
sofort in ein wenig so genannte
winterkrieg gestürzt ist gegen
sowjetunion sehr viele schwedische
freiwillige da waren und überhaupt
es gibt so eine ein ausdruck finnlands
sache ist unsere sache das ist eine
tradition und das war man darf auch
nicht vergessen dass nach dem kalten
krieg war es eine parallele
antrag wann die eu und die schwedin
pilgern ist am selben tag erster januar
also das ist logisch dass auch diese
unerwartete nach parallel okay herr
krause wenn man das jetzt sieht also
beitritt von finnland und dann wohl ja
auch schweden die nato hat heute gesagt
wir empfangen sie mit offenen armen
was was heißt das für unsere neue
ordnung auf dem kontinent
na ja zunächst mal vollziehen beide
länder etwas nach was ja in anderen
bereichen schon besteht sie sind
marktwirtschaften sie sind demokratien
sie sind unzweifelhaft teil der
westlichen welt kulturell politisch in
jeder hinsicht
dass sie nun auch dem militärbündnis
beizutreten jahr hat sie suchen den
schutz der gemeinschaft und
schweden weiß ich es nicht so genau aber
finnland kanten der nato auch eine menge
bieten finden findet ist ein deutlich
besser gerüstet das land militärisch als
deutschland es kann über 200.000
soldaten sehr schnell mobilisieren
finnland hat immer mit dem ernstfall
gelebt ist hat sich immer bedroht
gefühlt durch russland und war hat sich
immer gewappnet es gibt der zivilschutz
zum beispiel der bei uns völlig
verwundert ist er der ist in finnland
extrem gut ausgebauten unter jedem
größeren wohnhaus gibt es bunker ist
die bevölkerung nicht dafür dass man
meint man sieht ja dass putin ein land
das alleine ist überfährt über zu
überfallen markt und dass er sich an
nichts mehr hält das problem ist
das ist der große unterschied zur
sowjetunion die sowjetunion hat sich
formal an internationale abmachungen und
regeln gehalten
und und nicht nur formal aber wenn sie
sich irgendwo haben rufen lassen wenn
sie irgendwo interveniert haben haben
sie sich von der amtierenden regierung
rufen lassen das war nicht immer so dass
es uns gefiel aber aber sie haben sich
formal an das völkerrecht gehalten putin
tritt alles mit füßen die schlussakte
von helsinki dts die un charta
alles was da ist dass das berühmte
budapester memorandum in dem russland
die grenzen der ukraine garantiert so
und deswegen ist russland nicht mehr
berechenbar man muss mit dem putin
russland mit allem rechnen untersuchen
schweden und finnland einfach den schutz
der gemeinschaft die stärke des die nato
bietet den schutz auch durch die usa
dass der große unterschied zur eu die
uhr auf zwei stunden begrenzt mit
russland 1300 kilometer frau priesmeier
man jetzt sollte man als erste reaktion
aus dem kreml man fühlte sich jetzt
bedroht und man würde auch antworten wie
hoch ist die gefahr ihrer meinung nach
dass der konflikt jetzt weiter eskaliert
wenn
und schäden nato mitglied sind
also erstmal es ist noch ein sehr langer
weg bis beide länder natürlich
nato-mitglieder werden es geht erstmal
darum dass wir diese absicht erklären
dass das natürlich dieser ganze
aufnahmeprozess startet in falten hat
dauert es ein bisschen kürzer als zum
beispiel bei einem eu beitritt ist etwas
hinblick auf die ukraine was brauchen
natürlich in der diskussion steht
und dann muss natürlich noch der
ratifikationsprozess
anstehen auch die parlamente müssen
ratifizieren und so weiter und so fort
also wir reden erst mal überhaupt über
diese absicht mitglied der nato zu verdi
ist ja schon vorher sollen als ich
gerade die werden nicht morgen die
werden auch nicht demnächst natürlich
das ist hier ein sie das überlebt man
sind das wäre ich glaube dieses dieser
diese diskussion
natürlich man will es beschleunigen man
will auch natürlich zeigen dass die
europäische gemeinschaft sei es die
europäische union als auch die nato in
diesem fall auch schnell reagieren
können und auch natürlich zusammenhalten
können diese diskussionen diese rhetorik
von putin dass sie sich immer bedroht
führt das hören wir schon sehr sehr
lange aber er macht genau das gegenteil
also ich meine er hat hier nicht die
ukraine angegriffen weil sich von der
nato bedroht fühlte sondern weil er sich
einfach mal ausgedacht hat okay ich
brauche diese diese ich brauche eine
unabhängige ukraine
ich will eine eigene einflusssphäre
haben ich will einfach mal meinen
einfluss in der region in den
postsowjetischen raum auch sichern und
das waren die gründe alles andere ist
einfach nur eine erklärung und ich denke
wir müssen das wirklich deutlich sehen
es ist ein ersatz erklärung zu zu einer
großmacht fantasie von putin unterstrich
auch im browser zu das ist eine politik
die bisher wir von moskau so nicht
kennen weil tatsächlich auch im kalten
krieg sich russland meistens oder die
sowjetunion an die abmachungen gehalten
was aber dann ist zurzeit sehr
unberechenbar was dann aber das ist aber
dann auch mal schwieriger als wenn sie
sagen als unberechenbar dann ist
natürlich dass jetzt könnte das ja noch
mal einen extra
eine soziale öl ins feuer gehen es gab
als erster reaktionen jetzt die
androhung dass man
in den gashahn zudreht also auch auf
dieser art könnte ja kein russland
reagieren
hier natürlich aber das ist ja auch ein
bisschen zu die frage die wir uns als
europäische gemeinschaft stellen müssen
reagieren wir haben solche androhungen
und halten wir uns zurück weil wir die
angst vor dem großen bären haben oder
sind wir bereit ein bestimmtes risiko
aufzunehmen weil natürlich die länder
schweden finnland ja auch unsere
verbündete sind auch innerhalb der
europäischen union und wir auch eine
gewisse verpflichtungen auch innerhalb
der eu bei der ideen gegenüber haben und
selbstverständlich auch diese
beitrittsgesuch ernst nehmen
natürlich es gibt ja immer diese gefahr
vor diesem roten knopf sie war ja auch
sofort da nachdem wir im bundestag die
zeitenwende diskussion gehört haben oder
die zeitenwende rede
aber wir dürfen uns glaube ich nicht
allzu stark weil diese gefahr da
möglicherweise natürlich irgendwo da ist
nur durch diese angst vor dem roten
knopf seiten also wir müssen auch zu
unseren europäischen werten stehen ja
und natürlich auch dazu gehört betrieben
sicherheit demokratie aber auch der
beistand und solidarität unter dirigent
wie bei den anderen ländern genau wie
wird das bei ihnen in frankreich
diskutiert es gibt es um eine diskussion
über die eu da reden wir gleich noch mal
drüber aber natürlich auch über die nato
das spielt jetzt im
neuen wahlkampf in frankreich eine rolle
also wie wird das wahrgenommen wenn
jetzt schweden finnland sagen sie wollen
teil der nato werden also das ist sehr
interessant weil machen erklärt seit
fünf jahren schon er möchte ein paar
mehr europäische souveränität und diesen
begriff wurde oft nichts verstanden
unter dem motto was bedeutet dass mehr
souveränität mehr richtung verteidigung
für viele europäer ist unsere
verteidigung garantiert durch nato und
das ist natürlich diese diese position
von frankreich die sagt wir wollen mehr
europäische souveränität mehr
europäische verteidigung jetzt muss mit
diesem krieg muss tatsächlich makro
erkennen ohne nato wäre das nicht
möglich dass wir uns sicher fühlen und
deshalb hat er ein bisschen sein diskurs
ein bisschen geändert und spielt jetzt
auf beide auf beide säule sozusagen und
begrüßt natürlich offiziell dass
schweden und finnland jetzt in die nato
eintreten wollen interessant ist er ist
da momentan als neu gewählte oder
wiedergewählte präsident hat ja bestimmt
eine große legitimität und ist eine
große stimme momentan aber frankreich
ist noch nicht vorbei wir im wahlkampf
wir haben die parlamentswahlen mitte
juni und das haben wir bei dem ersten
wahlgang der
präsidentschaftswahl gesehen im april
wir haben drei blöcke in frankreich
makro in der mieter und an diese
linksextrem lager geführt von mir noch
schonen rechtsextreme lager geführt von
marine le pen und beide wollen dass
frankreich aus der nato zurück kommt aus
der führung
erst mal erst mal aber das ist sehr
diffus und sehr wichtig bleibt also das
ist natürlich mit diesem populisten
immer sehr unklar weil sie ganz genau
wollen und die haben so beide auch ein
bisschen ihre position ändern wissen ja
dass eine rolle dass man sagt man hat
man hätte man hat jetzt man befürchte
dass der krieg weiter eskaliert durch
diesen neuen nato länder das ist das ist
das klassische sich kurzmann mir auch
schon zum beispiel der also ich hab es
noch heute die guckte zum letzten mal
war er 2018 in deutschland in berlin bei
dem parteitag der linkspartei und in
seine räder sagt er ganz genau die
gefahr heißt es russland die gefahr ist
nato und der usa und diese position hat
ja noch im januar verteidigt okay also
das ist natürlich jetzt wie bereitet er
natürlich entstehen ja aber da steht
noch im fall programm von ihm herr
neumann sie haben ja gesagt dass in
finnland und schweden sich die dass die
bevölkerung sich dass er sich verändert
hat dass man eine große zustimmung jetzt
hat wie viel angst gibt es dann aber
trotzdem davor dass man jetzt dass
russland jetzt reagiert auf die tatsache
dass man um dann diesen antrag stellt
ich sage wer es gibt eine größere
sage mir verteidigungs interesse jetzt
dass es vor einem jahr gab es werden
genau wie deutschland aber zum beispiel
15 jahre der wehrmacht pflicht
abgeschafft dann wieder weder eingeführt
vor ein paar jahren
aber die den verteidigungsbudget war
gesunken und ist dazu noch immer jetzt
auf
9,3 prozent knapp vorne von wo
internationale produkt- und
man hat er schon durch die allgemeine
spannungen in den letzten monaten eine
debatte wo man sagt ja wir werden zwei
prozent bereich mit oder ohne
nato-mitgliedschaft einfach um uns
selber besser verteidigen so können zwei
prozent bnp vor 20 28 so es ist diese
bewegung gibt es unter den bürgern und
unter den politiker aber die skepsis
gegen nato gegenüber war sehr stark bis
24 februar zum beispiel also partner mit
erdogan zum beispiel war eine
dimension die den schweden nicht so
besonders gefallen hat
und auch die erfahrungen von der tramp
regierung war auch etwas mehr so
abschreckend als locken für für schweden
und aber es die bürgerliche parteien
waren die ganze zeit in den letzten zehn
jahren für eine einer
nato-mitgliedschaft appetit
sozialdemokratie und die linken und die
grünen waren bis jetzt dagegen dieses
jahr demokraten ändern ändert sich jetzt
gerade
und wird am montag
wahrscheinlich eine neue entscheidung
also sehen wir dass wenn das sich über
alle den bei den parteien da viel tut in
ganz europa
und darüber hinaus genau so wenn man
aber jetzt immer früher gesagt hat man
die naht die ukraine sollen nicht nato
mitglied werden damit dass russland
nicht provoziert das das war ja die idee
und jetzt wird aber finnland als
grenzland nato mitglied und ist ist er
nicht mehr neutral
der westen hat auf russland sehr viel
rücksicht genommen und ist auch so
gewollt über jahrzehnte hinweg
deswegen ist ja das ganze russische
gerede oder putins gerede von einer
bedrohung durch die nato so völliger
irrsinn in einer zeit als russland
wirklich schwach war denn wenn die nato
wenn der westen da was gewollt hätte
hätte hätten wir das sind billig und
ganz leicht haben können kein mensch
will russland bedrohen das und dass
russland in sicherheit leben soll den
natürlich das ist ein berechtigtes
interesse
jetzt haben wir gemerkt dass die russen
aber sehr viele unberechtigte interessen
verfolgen dass die rücksichtnahme sich
nicht ausgezahlt wir haben gedacht hat
dass das ich dass das handel für
stabilität sorgt dass das eher für
wandel sorgt eine der bedeutendsten
diplomaten deutschland china hat mal
gesagt wir haben den mit den russen die
deutsche einheit verhandeln können dann
haben wir auch gedacht dann schaffen wir
es auch in ihre großmacht träume weg zu
verhandeln und das dass man da das dass
die europäer frankreich und deutschland
damals die die aufnahme der ukraine und
georgiens in die nato abgelehnt haben
war ein akt der rücksichtnahme gegenüber
russland russland hat jetzt gezeigt das
ist keinerlei rücksichtnahme honoriert
das ist ein eigenes ding macht putin
macht sein ding und er droht nach
belieben und er handelt nach belieben
und und und das ist nicht nur das dass
das jetzt wenn schweden und finnland
sagen sie wollen die nato dass das
gerade als zeichen eben der stärke
gesehen wird und nicht unbedingt als
bedrohung ich glaube der westen hat gar
keine andere wahl als jetzt jetzt nicht
mehr zu fragen was denkt russland will
russland sondern der westen muss jetzt
sein eigenes ding machen die länder
müssen entscheiden wie sie sich besser
fühlen so und danach müssen sie sich
ausrichten die drohung aus moskau wird
es geben aber die wird es auch geben
wenn wir das nicht machen was was wir
machen wollen wenn finnland nicht in die
nato warum wollen sie finden die finnen
haben die angst dass sie nach der
ukraine das nächste land wenn es
angegriffen ja und andere länder haben
auch als solche sowie im länder des
baltikums fabrice mal würde ich sie auch
gern fragen auch andere länder haben
natürlich angst moldawien das baltikum
also wie muss man ja oder bier wie ist
da die reaktion
ja also ich würde noch mal zwei punkte
sagen einmal jetzt mit dem russischen
angriff auf die ukraine hat sich glaube
ich so ein bisschen auch die
westeuropäische
awards europäische vorstellung soll ein
bisschen
zu nicht erklärt dass man eine
möglichkeit hat eine reihe auch von
neutralen staaten zu haben zwischen
russland und unter europäischen und den
westeuropäischen staaten nach dem motto
okay wir könnten es versuchen so ein
bisschen die diesen interessenkonflikt
zu glätten indem wir am hotel schäden am
modell finnland auch natürlich auch die
ukraine oder georgien als neutrale
staaten anerkennen und dadurch einfach
mal ein bisschen ruhe haben das ist und
da da gebe ich ihnen hier große auch
recht das hat sich einfach mal jetzt mit
der mit der klaren stellung von finnland
und dann natürlich auch schweden
deutlich deutlich abgelöst und das wird
wahrscheinlich auch nicht ein thema sein
also wir werden davon ausgehen dass wir
tatsächlich mal zu weiteren
erweiterungen kommen dass seite ist
dieses thema bedrohung das ist sehr sehr
wichtig weil sie das jetzt gerade eben
auch angesprochen im hinblick auf die
baltischen staaten es gibt zwei sorten
von bedrohungen diese typische
militärische bedrohung die wir spüren
was man sich normalerweise den krieg
vorstellt nämlich panzer waffen
bomben und so weiter und so fort das
spielt sich gerade natürlich auch in der
ukraine sehr stark ab das andere ist
natürlich auch mal diese cyber bedrohung
die die cyber warfare die tatsächlich
auch eine eine enorme bedrohung auf
unsere infrastruktur da stand auf
unserer banken wir die baltischen
staaten haben das sehr sehr stark erlebt
anfang der 2000er jahre das war ja auch
der grund warum sie unbedingt auch in
die nato wollten weil sie sagten so okay
es ist auch eine eine bedrohung die wir
die wir selber nicht stemmen können
beziehungsweise wie auch die
unterstützung natürlich von den anderen
staaten haben und wenn
das müssen wir glaube ich natürlich auch
berücksichtigen bei in diesem ganzen
zusammenhang ansonsten die baltischen
staaten haben natürlich sehr sehr
positiv reagiert auf die wörter von
finnland und weil für sie bedeutet
tatsächlich mal beitritt finnlands und
schwedens in die nato auch eine
eine stärkung großer sicherheit
weil sie dann natürlich auch besser
geschützt natürlich spielt eine enorme
das spielt auch eine rolle für polen
letzter punkt weil polen natürlich mit
litauen durch ein ganz ganz ganz engen
lande strich verbunden ist das ist so
dieses gespräch es ist ein paar
kilometer ansonsten haben wie kann ich
ihn gerade auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite es ist belarus das heißt
stärkung der örtlichen flanke der nato
würde bedeuten dass auch natürlich
insgesamt auch mehr sicherheit in der
region dort die normale traditionelle
aber auch natürlich die in
konventionelle was würde das denn heißen
wenn man sich vorstellt wie die wie
europa oder die welt nach einem krieg
aussehen könnte wenn wir über die
zukunft mit russland nachdenken herr
neumann wäre dann nicht der klare
schluss dass man sagen muss ja dann muss
auch die ukraine wenn dieser krieg mal
irgendwann vorbei ist letztendlich in
die nato kommen weil als neue als ein
neutraler staat wird es nicht mehr
funktionieren
ja
das klingt ja fast logisch
bis 24 februar war ich selber und ich
denke relativ repräsentative viele
schweden gemeinten eine gewisse personen
die von netzneutralität und
ausstellungen war ja immer als bündnis
frei in frieden neutral im krieg das
wesen guten gegend 200 jahre lang und
wir hatten ja und jetzt 18 bis 24 im
februar dass
schwedens und finnlands
neutralität eine gewisse
stabilisierende faktor war für die
sicherheits für europa überhaupt für
nordeuropa besonders und für europa
überhaupt und uns war es wohl auch nicht
fallen die idee dass vielleicht
ukraine sich dann auch unabhängig eine
in einem gewissen moment eher wie man
sie sich vielleicht als zu gast jetzt
gesagt ja das würde er belegen in diesem
nicht so gelungenen
friedensverhandlungen
aber nach der invasion und besonders wie
sich der so alles kriegsverbrecher
verbrechen uns so weiter entwickelt hat
wird wohl fast auch ukrainers
mitgliedschaft in
der nato logisch es wäre zu sehen dass
das nicht so ein punkt aber auch
georgien wie sie sich erinnern 2008 war
ja ein grund für russlands angriff
damals dass
georgien sehr ernst mit
nato-mitgliedschaft sozusagen geflirtet
haben ok also
bleiben wir mal noch kommen oder gehen
wir von der nato mal eben noch auf die
eu also wenn wir sagen wenn wir über
darüber reden wie denn eine zukunft der
ukraine oder des europäischen kontinents
aussehen könnte jetzt verändert durch
diesen angriffskrieg frau kohl da gibt
es ja jetzt auch ein vorschlag von von
makro der eine europäische politische
gemeinschaft will also nicht mehr
richtige vollmitgliedschaft sondern eine
art zweiter klasse europa wie muss man
es verstehen vielleicht erkennen sie es
uns besser was er da will und warum er
das jetzt vorschlägt die er wie er sich
die kunden wie er sich das vorstellt
auch gerade mit der ukraine
also das ist jetzt noch also nicht sehr
klar muss man sagen also ergreift dabei
eine sehr alte idee dass mit der eine
idee die miete
am anfang von jahren
1991 ausgedrückt hatte das war noch
diese zeit nach der nach dem mauerfall
wie kommt man klar in diese neue wellen
diese neue konstellation und mietete die
idee von einer ernannte das damals
europäische konföderation also eine
staatenbund sozusagen
sein idee ist gescheitert aus zwei
gründen
eigentlich die ost länder wollten
schnell der nato die wollen erst mal in
die nato kann die haben ein bisschen
angst dass durch diesen dieser
konfiguration sie diese diese schutz der
natur nicht bekommen könnte und zweitens
wollte metro das ist auch interessant
russland auch mit dabei hatten und das
hat natürlich washington nicht gefallen
und so ist es einfach gescheitert
diesmal es ist natürlich nicht die frage
dass russland auch noch kommt
das ist auch aber das bleibt die gleiche
idee von einer haben sie gesagt europa
zweiter klasse die frage ist wer wir
dass ein vorzimmer sein erwartet zimmer
seien zur eu oder wir das den ewigen
fegefeuer sein für leute die den
kriterien für länder die diese kriterien
nicht erfüllen ich kann schon verstehen
warum einige länder mit den ideen nicht
einverstanden sind
das müssen wir allerdings alle zusammen
diskutieren und ich glaube das wird auch
noch kommen beim dem nächsten gipfel
ende juni danach aber wird tschechien
die den präsidentschafts der eu hat
haben und dann schweden und dann ist es
auch interessant
vielleicht kann unser team hat hier auch
noch was dazu sagen ob man auch erwarten
kann dass tschechien und schweden auch
wie der idee weiterkommen also was hat
dieser was verändert dieser krieger
krause dass man also in unsere
überlegung wie die eu in zukunft sein
soll wenn die ukraine jetzt sagt also
annalena baerbock hat gesagt so geht von
einer vollmitgliedschaft irgendwann aus
seiner rede auch von vollmitgliedschaft
will aber keine falschen versprechungen
machen herr kollege hat heute gesagt er
wird schon mal einen platz reservieren
also wird das werk warten lässt man
bitte ab die erfahrungen die die eu mit
erweiterungen gemacht hat sind ja nicht
nur positiv und man hat wie ich finde
dummerweise immer nur die
vollmitgliedschaft genommen zettel zb
das instrument des europäischen
wirtschaftsraums gegeben wo mittels
staaten erst mal an die eu herangeführt
worden wären alle wirtschaftlichen
vorteile gehabt hätten aber sich auch
mental hätten ernähren können wir wissen
was wir heute mit ungarn und teilweise
mit polen für schwierigkeiten haben
teilweise auch mit slowenien
ich bin mit der ukraine noch sehr
skeptisch der der glühen der
nationalismus der der ukraine gerade
hilft in diesem krieg zu bestehen ist in
der eu ein hindernis die eu baut darauf
auf dass die länder eben sich nicht
nationalistisch verhalten und das ist
das ist zum beispiel die große skepsis
die immer noch serbien entgegen schlägt
so und das und und muss man sehen die eu
ist anders als die nato das ist ein
gebilde buch wo wir alle miteinander
dieselbe diese souveränität teilen das
heißt die anderen regieren uns mit wir
regieren die anderen mit so wollen wir
von den anderen in diesem zustand mit
regiert werden das ist keine ganz
einfache sache und die ganzen
praktischen fragen was allem
wirtschaftlich geregelt ist das ist noch
ein langer prozess ich muss mir noch die
zeiten von priestern herr naumann bitte
vorher ist ja bitte ich würde gerne herr
krause ganz kurz unterbrechen
widersprechen in diesem falle nämlich es
ist tatsächlich 18 jahre her als er die
große eu erwarte er gab aber es ist ein
bisschen anders wir haben damals alle
unglaublich sorgen gehabt dass polen
ungarn andere mittel und osteuropäischen
staaten es wirtschaftlich nicht schaffen
das hauptargument war damals zu sagen
die länder sind nicht soweit
wirtschaftlich genug um tatsächlich mal
mit den europäischen standards
mitzuhalten deswegen hatten wir so lange
übergangsfristen deswegen gab es ja
natürlich nochmal diese schwierigkeiten
mit dem arbeitsmarkt und so weiter und
so fort aber das hat sich aber gezeigt
dass wirtschaftlich eigentlich diese
länder wunderbar und relativ schnell
aufgeholt haben polen war das erste land
oder das einzige land hinter finanzen
finanz und wirtschaftskrise das wirklich
mal positive wirtschaftszahlen während
alle anderen rote zahlen hatten das
war's aber nicht funktioniert hat oder
es stimmte das thema rechtsstaatlichkeit
thema demokratie aber das nehmen wir
nicht nur in polen und ungarn sondern
das erleben wir natürlich auch in allen
anderen oder in vielen auch etablierten
westeuropäischen demokratien also dieses
argument zu sagen okay wir haben
schlechte erfahrungen mit der
erweiterung gemacht deswegen müssen wir
vorsichtig sein dass man sich ein
bisschen beiseite stellen und zu sagen
nein wirtschaftlich ist das ein erfolg
dieses thema die polit also thema dem
aber die so eine so schlecht dass man
sagt das was der browser das man eben
gesagt man macht erstmal ein
wirtschaftsraum und man macht geben
keine vollmitgliedschaft dass das wäre
doch dann verlassen weil die am 7 ja
aber das haben wir ja schon
ja aber wir haben natürlich mit der
ukraine schonen nach der revolution der
würde
2014 für tief des verhandelns abkommen
und assoziierungsabkommen unterschrieben
und das ist tatsächlich so eine art
mitgliedschaft - sie merken dass hier
auch es gab schon jetzt vor dem krieg in
der ukraine
viele waren ukrainische waren in den
supermärkten ukrainischer
arbeiter auf dem deutschen arbeitsmarkt
natürlich auch wie stark hat empfohlen
das heißt die mitgliedschaft - gibt es
schon die frage ist jetzt tatsächlich
ist wäre jetzt zeit nicht nur etwas
daneben zu haben sondern tatsächlich
langsam auch den leiter hoch hin zur
mitgliedschaft uns zu arbeiten in dem
prozess ist lang das wird denn sie ja
das ist klar das ist ja noch lange
dauern und ich würde gerne hier ich
würde gerne aber es geht um den
kandidatenstatus genau ok herr naumann
wie sehen sie wird es auch von von
schweden aus gesehen wenn man sagt die
eu muss sich da verändern oder es muss
zwei geschwindigkeiten auch das war ja
auch mal thema oder so eine art ja zwei
arten der mitgliedschaft geben
ich bin ja kein offizieller vertreter
ich bin
nie darüber gesprochen was in ihrem land
als wir es ist die schwedische linie war
immer
pro erweiterung weil der mann hat eu vor
allen dingen als ein friedensprojekt
gesehen also je mehr mitglieder in der
eu desto größer der größere garantie für
friedliche verhältnisse zwischen den
europäischen mitgliedstaaten und starten
überhaupt
europarat zum beispiel hat dann nicht
gereicht sondern die enge zusammenarbeit
ein
jetzt ist die verbindung glaube ich
etwas
unterbrochen
ja dann okay die ist jetzt kurz
unterbrochen dann spreche ich einfach
nochmal hier weiter frage wollten ja
genau erweiterung ist gut also ich
glaube jetzt haben wir auch gesehen im
pandemie und so weiter wir brauchen eine
vertiefung und das ist jetzt auch tief
in die frage es war immer so als ich
noch studentin war immer vertiefung
erweiterung kann man jetzt beide
zusammen führen indem man sagt es gibt
eine zweite
liga der europäische länder sozusagen
die nicht das vorhaben ich verstehe
vollen klar dass das sehr sehr
kompliziert ist und ich würde mich
überhaupt nicht freuen wenn ich aus
bosnien er sie gewinnen komme oder und
das hörer vielleicht freuen sich auch
vielleicht die engländer dazu weil da
können sie vielleicht noch mal an den
führenden europäischen schiff daran
gekoppelt werden aber eine möglichkeit
als wäre daran müssen wir auf jeden fall
noch diskutieren sie sagt immer küssen
kann man nicht alleine nur der vorschlag
von frankreich kann nicht eine lösung
sein für alle wir müssen das auf jeden
fall offen diskutieren und aber wir
müssen das auch schnell machen ich höre
dort es wird lange dauern lange dauern
und so weiter die gefahr ist da
deutschland ist so glaube ich auch eher
skeptisch also sieht es ja so positiv
oder hat sich zu hat sich zumindest
erstmal zurückhaltend also scholz hat
gesagt das ist ein interessanter
vorschlag
hat aber sofort gesagt wir müssen auch
gucken wir das jetzt mit dem länder der
der westbalkan ist das nicht wieder eine
art krause wo es dann noch mal wieder
viel komplizierter würde wo alles
nochmal viel länger dauert wo wir doch
jetzt eigentlich merken das wichtigste
ist dass man dass die eu einig ist also
bei solchen sachen wie jetzt auch den
sanktionen das ist ja kompliziert die eu
hat in den letzten jahren keine gute
entwicklung genommen hierzu stehe
innerer zustand ist schrecklich und und
er ist ja nicht gesichert ich meine
lassen sie in frankreich dieses
linksbündnis gewinnen was nicht was
nicht ganz ausgeschlossen ist dann wird
der ungehorsam gegen das gegenüber dem
brüssel sozusagen zur politik spricht
dann hält man sich nicht mehr an die
spielregeln die man mal gemeinsam
verabredet hat dass das ist ein schlag
gegen die eu den sie kaum überleben kann
so dass ich sagen alle die eu war so
einige ist jetzt in dieser in diesem
kreis einig die eigentlich ja seit
ewigkeiten wir haben die eu hat ich
gebrauche gern den begriff der
wehrhaftigkeit deshalb fehlt der eu an
wehrhaftigkeit nach außen aber auch nach
innen wir haben nicht für disziplin
unter den mitgliedern gesorgt hat hat
unsere frühere bundesregierung und
grandiose versäumnisse sich zu schulden
kommen lassen so und jetzt muss man
daraus was machen es gibt ja
gleichzeitig das ist nun mal so sie
haben doch sowieso zwei
geschwindigkeiten ist neben längst nicht
alle eu-länder euro teil längst nicht
alle am schengen system und und dass die
länder die mehr wollen und das müssen
vor allem frankreich und deutschland
seien aber da ist frankreich eben im
moment ein risikofaktor die dass die das
machen müssen ja dann sollen die das
auch tun können und die anderen die nur
an der wirtschaft interessiert sind die
werden dann nur an der wirtschaft
interessiert sein ungarn hat an der
politischen union der eben kein
interesse und polen nur teilweise und
und uns will sich jedenfalls nicht an
die standards halten das muss man zur
kenntnis nehmen dass sind demokratien
die da drückt sich auch oft genug ein
volkswille aus und da sind minderheiten
die das anders sehen aber die minderheit
sind minderheiten so und das heißt doch
nicht dass wir damit dass europa klingt
das wir wollen für eine scholz ist man
schon sehr entgegen gekommen als er
gesagt hat den begriff der europäischen
souveränität dass er denen sich zu eigen
gemacht hat anders als frau merkel und
in der tat muss man ihn mit inhalten
füllen und ich bin nicht sicher dass die
deutschen und die franzosen dasselbe
meinen aber der aber darüber muss man
diskutieren und das kann man vereinbaren
weil diese europäische souveränität ist
notwendig und wenn wir dann jetzt
nochmal in die zukunft wieder kommt
helfen zum beispiel wenn wir dann aber
jetzt mal in die zukunft schauen wie
könnte denn so ein miteinander in europa
und auch mit russland und dem platz der
ukraine wie könnte das dann aussehen
frau pries mal was was machen sie sich
dafür vorstellung wir müssen ja auch
irgendwie mit russland weiter umgehen
wir hatten eigentlich so ein traum und
das nennt sich die aus also die
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa die ja wir
werden nächstes jahr 50 jahre helsinki
schlussakte feiern
leider natürlich merken wir dass diese
organisationen zurzeit papiertiger ist
aufgrund natürlich auf und ihre
integrierten struktur alle müssen sich
einigen alle müssen arbeiten natürlich
russland blockiert weder ross blockiert
aber wenn wir wirklich so über das große
europa sprechen müssen wir schauen ja es
wäre vielleicht gute möglichkeit zu
gucken wir können wir verständigung wege
schaffen wie können wir plattformen
schaffen in rahmen bestehende
organisation aber auch außerhalb davon
wo wir miteinander ins gespräch kommen
wenn es auf der politischen ebene nicht
möglich ist vielleicht gelingt das auch
die zivilgesellschaftlichen ebene dass
sie so ein kleines bisschen
wahrscheinlich zur rückkehr zu der
schlussakte von helsinki
aber in den jetzigen zeiten ist das
glaube ich die einzige
sinnvolle lösung oder im single
sinnvolle möglichkeit das geht alle
großen erklären natürlich auch hoffen
dass bald veränderungen genau dass bald
auch veränderungen
in russland selbst geschrieben können
und wir da einfach auch neue
gesprächskanäle offen haben können herr
nochmals sie sind wieder da ihre leitung
steht wieder
sie wollten
ich habe wahnsinnig viele russische
freunde die sind jetzt fallen die sind
alle weg von moskau das in finnland in
berlin in georgien in verschiedenen
ländern die sind einfach geflohen und
als ein für europa
eine wirklichkeit vorhaben ohne ruß ohne
kontakte mit russland ist ja so in lang
langfristig eigentlich undenkbar weil
ostern liegt vor sich oder wo es liegen
und man kann das nicht einfach wegdenken
so ein tag muss ja irgendwie eine
normalisierung wieder da kommen aber es
geht wahrscheinlich nicht so lange da
ist das ist das schlimme und wir werden
dann in ein vakuum gegen was ja
natürlich besonders tragisch ist für
alle wichtige fragen die die
weltgemeinschaft zu diskutieren hat
klimakrise und jetzt auch
hungerkrise und den dramatische
entwicklungen oder mangelnde entwicklung
in der dritten welt und alles das mit
mit einer komplett isolierte russland
die vielleicht ein bisschen beziehung
mit indien und china hat aber sonst
nicht das ist einfach tragisch und
langfristig undenkbar langfristig und
denkbar im moment sicherlich nicht
anders machen frage ist doch was wollen
sie mit einem russland machen dass sich
an keinen vertrag hält an kein abkommen
wo dessen führer lügen wie gedruckt fast
jeden tag dass das muss man ja auch alle
denen sagen die jetzt statt waffenhilfe
für die ukraine zu leisten dauernd auch
verhandlungen bestehen was wollen sie
mit denen verhandelt am ende von
verhandlung muss ein abkommen stehen
russland hielt sich nicht an abkommen
das heißt so und gleichzeitig ist klar
man kann den präsidenten einer atommacht
nicht militärisch besiegen das geht
nicht das heißt es hängt von den
entwicklungen in russland ab was künftig
mit russland geht das erläutert das ist
ja ok aber das hieße ja dass man sich
sozusagen
man kann sich als eu doch auch 14 habt
wenn es mal anders haben wir dürfen
unsere sorgen haben aber aber nicht mehr
beeindrucken lassen durch das was da in
moskau gesagt wird und dann sollen sie
mit atomwaffen wenn sie die zünden
wollen werden sie es tun
sodann ist denn dann kommt die die
katastrophe über uns alle aber dann
kommt die katastrophe auch über sie weiß
nicht ob er ein putin dass in russland
durchsetzen kann das ist warten will ich
aber auch gar nicht ergründen wir müssen
jetzt davon ausgehen dass mit russland
nicht politik zu machen ist das ist doch
das entscheidende
das land liegt und dass astrid jedes
abkommen es gibt kein ab internationales
abkommen dass russland nicht mit füßen
tritt
und das einzige land in europa das
grenzen mit waffengewalt verschoben hat
oder verschieben wollte war russland in
den letzten jahrzehnten die frage ist
aber wie sich daneben europa aussieht
und was würde das dann bedeuten zum
beispiel in frankreich wenn die
parlamentswahl eben anders ausgeht wenn
er halt eben nicht lieber teil von makro
oder die mehrheit bekommt was würde das
bedeuten
groß sind sehr gute frage klar ist viele
viele wählerinnen und wähler in
frankreich fragen sie auch genau das
momentan meistens immer so der seite
deutschland frankreich das sind ist der
motor für die eu und das ist das
wichtige und wenn dieser jetzt halt eben
dann nicht genau also mir das wäre ein
klassischer fall der kavitation das
haben wir schon mal gehabt der 90er
jahren und auch in den 80er und 90er
jahre allerdings war das damals ein duo
also mitterrand und chirac und wiederum
bei der dir und deinen chirac und jasper
das war immer also zwei politiker mit
sehr klare unterschiede was
wirtschaftspolitik sozialpolitik ist
aber die gleiche werte an was diplomatie
außenpolitik und das bedeutete weil die
physische verfassung ist da nicht sehr
klar wer eigentlich mal frankreich
vertritt bei eu rat bei großen gipfel
und so weiter so ist es ist so gelungen
dass der premierminister eigentlich
sollte das er premierminister machen wie
der kanzler hier in deutschland aber
eben auch noch mal eine große
verunsicherung geben gehen und ich sage
mir auch schon tatsächlich zu nehmen
also der eine mehrheit bekommt da müssen
wir mal gucken ob man gut als ich ihn
welt als premierminister das ist immer
noch die große politik von präsident von
dem präsident aber wenn das geht ich
sehe da einfahren das ist das wird
einfach unmöglich sein dass mir noch
schon sagt du im manual du gehst jetzt
und vertrieb frankreich bei der eu er
wird auf jeden fall das für sich selbst
wollen und dann haben wir eine blockade
auf jeden fall im letzte fact also
vielleicht ein bisschen zur beruhigung
kann der präsident in frankreich immer
noch nochmal das parlament auflösen und
zu neuwahlen rufen so weit sind wir noch
nicht und es gibt noch wahlkampf
aber immerhin das ist ein faktor den man
mit bedenken muss wenn man über die
zukunft sehen denn in diesen schwierigen
zeiten genau und ich würde das aber gern
auch nochmal welt das ja nun der unsere
einer nachbar ist von deutschland vor
priesmeier aber polen neben der andere
nachbar ist und wie schaut man in polen
denn auf diese ganze entwicklung und
nach all diesen schwierigen prozessen
sie haben die rechtsstaatlichkeit
angesprochen also wie stellt man sich in
polen denn die zukunft mit der ukraine
vor
also polen ist zurzeit sehr stark so wie
sie auch mal früher in der vergangenheit
natürlich auch ein verfechter des
ukrainischen beitritts zur europäischen
union aber auch natürlich zum nato
auf der anderen seite wird natürlich
auch der westen sich da kritisiert für
die bisherige russische oder so russland
toleranter politik
und gleichzeitig und das müssen wir auch
deutlich mal sagen der
problematische kursen punkte
rechtsstaatlichkeit wird fortgesetzt
darüber wird natürlich wenig gesprochen
weil im schatten des krieges können
bestimmte entwicklungen einfach mal
besser an durchgesetzt werden das ist
aber auch ein thema wirklich für ein
anderes gespräch aber ich glaube so drei
lehrerinnen wenn wir aus dieser
diskussion aus diesem thema zukunft der
eu und der nato ziehen können ist es auf
jeden fall die reflexion a die bündnisse
helfen und es werden natürlich auch
stärkt die länder dem beitritt zur eu
dazu nato anstreben wollen weil sie
wissen ok in der gemeinschaft ist es
einfacher der wandel durch handel
funktioniert nicht das ist ja natürlich
die alte brandschutt politik die ist
eigentlich ziemlich lang ziemlich vor
einigen jahren verworfen worden aber ich
glaube letzten verfechter von dieser
politik können auch klar sagen es
funktioniert nicht es gibt handel durch
handeln ja das muss ganz ganz klar sein
aber wandel durch handel geht es nicht
und
die dritte aktion ist es tatsächlich
dass wir unabhängiger werden sollen
beziehungsweise wir müssen
diversifizieren das ist in puncto
energie in puncto handel in puncto
natürlich auch so zusammenarbeit eine
sehr sehr bittere dann würde ich eher
harte lektion die man so besser helfen
und nur selten und eine größere
unabhängigkeit wir sind am ende dieser
diskussion herr krause verbriefte
hannover nach stockholm herz zu große
frau coleen vielen dank ihren vielen
dank fürs zuschauen hier geht es weiter
mit phoenix der tag schön abend noch bis
dahin tschüss